Disney's Aladdin is the number one movie
in the world impressive I think that's
the president rusted eat wrestles and
dazzles show times and surprises in all
the right ways see you there
Disney's Aladdin rated PG prepare
yourself I'm ready hold on here we go
Disney's Aladdin is the number one movie
in the world I like that it's charming
and fun better than the best
entertaining and a complete delight
please don't forget to tip your genie on
the way out Disney's Aladdin rated PG
Genie I wish to become a prince I'm
about to fabulous you
[Music]
not enough huh rust is and now for your
entourage too small too obvious
somebody bought me out too bad Showtime
no I'm in charge
really really
[Music]
Disney so light it you can clap
rated PG in theaters May 24 tickets on
sale now Showtime
critics can't stop raving about Aladdin
yes impressive study I like that
the most fun you'll have it to movies ah
cedar it's a magical adventure whoa
never seen our before and great for the
whole family I did most of the work he
was just standing there Disney's Aladdin
rated PG be the first to see it tonight
[Music]
do you trust me Disney's a lotta rated
PG now play
you